ich übertreibe nicht Sensation zum
ersten Mal überhaupt in der Geschichte
des Landes schlagen die sogenannten
Wirtschaftsweisen vor für die reichsten
5% der deutschen Steuern vorübergehend
zu erhöhen totaler Schock wirklich
immerhin hat Christian Lindner
versprochen diesen Vorschlag in Ruhe zu
prüfen
das passiert
ist schon passiert denn drei Sekunden
später hat er fertig geprüft
Steuererhöhung wird es mit der FDP nicht
geben Debatte beendet auch die
öffentliche dafür streitet das Land seit
Wochen aufgeregt über das Bürgergeld am
Montag im Bundesrat von der Union
gestoppt weil mit dem Bürgergeld käme ja
auch das furchtbare und viel zu hohe
schon vermögen es geht eben im Kern um
ein Schonvermögen bei einer
Bedarfsgemeinschaft mit zwei Kindern von
150.000 Euro die man besitzt sind kann
und trotzdem Bürgergeld bekommen kann
die Mehrheit der Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer kann von einem solchen
vermögen nur träumen ja ganz genau alle
paar Meter hocken hier vermögende Hartz
IV Empfänger wie Gollum auf ihrem
150.000 Euro Schatz
in Wirklichkeit eine totale
Geisterdebatte gerade mal fünf Prozent
von denen Leben als Familie aus also als
Bedarfsgemeinschaft mit zwei Kindern und
von denen wiederum werden nicht allzu
viele 150 riesen auf der Kante haben
dabei müsste die Union sich doch
eigentlich mit den Harzern
solidarisieren wenn man darüber
nachdenkt
Opposition ist schließlich auch eine
Form von Arbeitslosigkeit ja ist doch so
[Applaus]
man kann am Bürgergeld schon was
verbessert Bürgergeld kritisieren völlig
okay aber CDU und CSU waren leider zu
faul sich ein eigenes Konzept zu
erarbeiten haben sie nicht ja und ihn
hier stört vor allem der Name ich glaube
es gibt einen Begriff Bürgergeld das
suggeriert dass jeder Mensch Anspruch
darauf hat und das ist das Kernproblem
des Bürgergeld ist kein anspruchsgeld
sondern es ist Geld des Sozialstaates
das ist es Bürgergeld das klingt ja fast
als Bernhards für Empfänger Bürger ja
nennt das doch Assi Almosen oder
pennerpauschale keine Ahnung
kann man nicht wenigstens bei den Fakten
bleiben Markus Söder zum Beispiel
behauptet stumpfweiter Bürgergeld bringe
mehr als Arbeit ja auch er füttert das
Klischee vom faulen Harzer der maximalen
Druck braucht obwohl gerade mal drei
Prozent von denen jemals mit Sanktionen
in Berührung kommen aber dann sowas hier
bei insta Posten gucken Sie mal an der
Münchner Tafel nicht sich der mülltätige
Monarch Markus unter die Bedürftigen und
Sülz ich habe leisten überragend
deswegen ganz wichtig gerade in diesen
Zeiten wo ähm viele Menschen nicht
wissen wie es mit der Energiepreisen
weitergeht die hohen Lebensmittelpreise
sind die Leisten die Tafeln und
verzichten Beitrag den Menschen Hoffnung
zu geben
ja weiß der Staat nicht macht was ein
Albtraum gehst du zur Tafel und dann
steht da der Söder
und poliert die Zucchini das kann doch
nicht wahr sein ja der und genauso
Friedrich Merz behaupten seit Wochen man
müsste arme Menschen mit Drohung und
Strafen zum Arbeiten zwingen es ist ja
ungefähr die Idee von denen ja
wer Sozialleistung kriegt soll irgendwie
leiden hey vielleicht kann man da sogar
eine Fernsehshow draus machen willkommen
bei Takeshis Bürgergeld da rennt man das
Kandidat geschlossene Türen ein rutscht
immer wieder ab auf der sozialen Leiter
und muss dann auch noch fiesen
Sanktionen ausweichen ist nicht einfach
wer findet im Jobcenter das Büro mit dem
zuständigen Sachbearbeiter keiner und
nur für den aller aller härtesten Wink
das unglaubliche Preisgeld von 500 2 €.
das reicht dank Inflation im nächsten
Jahr für einen Roggenbrot drei Paprika
und einen ganzen halben Liter Milch
Wahnsinn
[Applaus]
die sollen leiden für Bürgergeld
übrigens
apropos Fakten 80% der im
Hartz-IV-System möglich in Sanktionen
also jetzt schon möglich in Sanktionen
werden auch beim Bürgergeld in den
ersten sechs Monaten verhängt ich glaube
die Union sorgt sich hauptsächlich um
den Niedriglohnsektor ja der soll
erhalten bleiben Hartz IV Empfänger
sollen auch in Zukunft gezwungen werden
jeden Job anzunehmen auch Akademiker
übrigens ja klar oder denken die
Eierköpfe sie werden was besseres
ansonsten ist man bei der Union einfach
schadenfroh weil die SPD ihr
hartz-iv-trauma doch nicht so schnell
los wird eine Zwischenbemerkung
die meisten von uns arbeiten gerne
sieht man schon am Strand wenn Kinder
Sandburgen bauen
sandbogen bauen ist Arbeit
meine Ausbeute Eltern haben mir da
keinen pfennigfilm bezahlt
drei ja so sind wir Deutschen selbst
unsere Kinder wollen den ganzen Tag nur
arbeiten also fast alle Kinder
eines der letzten Tabuthemen in
Deutschland ein Drittel unserer
sozialleistungsempfänger ist jung
kerngesund denkt aber gar nicht daran zu
arbeiten sogenannte Kinder sie denken
wohl niedlich aussehen reicht und liegen
dem Staat Reisdorf der Tasche Schluss
damit
wer Kaufladen spielen kann der kann ja
wohl auch bei Rewe an der Kasse sitzen
oder Regale einräumen zumindest die
beiden unteren immer nur mit LEGO bauen
wie asozial und kindisch kann man sein
auf echten Baustellen fehlt das Personal
und wenn der Kleine Luca echt so gerne
Bobbycar fährt sondern aber wenigstens
Pizza ausfahren die faule Sau wir sagen
ein Kind das arbeitet muss mehr haben
als ein Kind das nicht arbeitet ihre CDU
ja
am nächsten Mittwoch trifft sich der
Vermittlungsausschuss mal gucken ob es
noch klappt mit dem Bürgergeld ab Januar
ich wette die Diskussion bleibt in jedem
Fall hitzig im Gegensatz zu der
übersteuererhöhung und das obwohl wir
gerade eine Ungleichheit haben in
Deutschland wie zuletzt in der
Kaiserzeit kein Witz wir könnten doch
für den Anfang wenigstens mal über
Erbschaftssteuern diskutieren ganz
aktuelle Meldung wer ab Januar Omas
Häuschen erbt zahlt plötzlich deutlich
mehr bei der Wert der Immobilie dann
irgendwie anders berechnet wird aber die
Erben von z.B sehr großen
Betriebsvermögen Zahlen weiterhin
praktisch gar keine Steuern da ist doch
eindeutig eine Schieflage fand schon das
Verfassungsgericht 2014 geändert hat
sich nichts für das ist Steuerberater
der heute so schön dass du da bist was
kannst du mir raten mir als Besitzer
eines normalen Einfamilienhauses ja gut
dass sie es ansprechen Herr welke sie
haben ja zwei söhn also die sie
anerkannt haben und es wäre wirklich
wichtig da den Erbfall noch im laufenden
Kalenderjahr eintreten zu lassen sonst
wird das für ihre Kinder bis zu 50%
teurer ja kann ich nachvollziehen aber
streng genommen bin ich ja noch nicht
tot ja aus steuerlicher Sicht muss man
sagen leider
wie wäre es denn im Hinblick darauf mal
mit einer Extremsportart anzufangen
Bungee Jumping Fallschirmspringen Blick
auf ihre Kondition würde für den Abfall
vielleicht schon fünf Minuten Joggen
reichen
ist das mit dem Laufenden gibt es
vielleicht noch eine andere Möglichkeit
ja gut wenn sie partout dieses Jahr
nicht versterben wollen egoistisch aber
bitte
da müssen wir zumindest versuchen
deutlich reicher zu werden so mittel
reich wie sie das macht überhaupt keinen
Sinn mit ihrem einen Haus da wenn das
jetzt sagen wir mal zwei drei tausend
Wohnungen werden dann werden sie ein
Wohnungsunternehmen und Zahlen im
Erbfall gar keine Steuern ja bin ich
aber nicht ja ich weiß es ist doof
gerade bei hohen Erbschaften und
Schenkungen gibt es wunderbare
Privilegien wir müssen doch auch wollen
wenn man sich die über 100 größten
Erbschaften Schenkungen der letzten
Jahre anschaut dann ist da im
Durchschnitt ein Steuersatz von etwa 1%
gezahlt worden nur ein Prozent weil
schlaue glaube ich verwende immer den
kleinen Handwerksbetrieb nach vorne
schieben der sonst von der
Erbschaftssteuer erwürgt würde
2016 hat der Bundesfinanzhof zuletzt
gesagt diese steuerpr Medien sind
verfassungswidrig wird aber ignoriert
von den Steuerbehörden auf Anweisung des
Finanzministers was es gibt doch noch
kein bekannten Fall wo Arbeitsplätze
durch Erbschaftssteuern verloren
gegangen sind darum geht es doch gar
nicht unsere Gesellschaft wird ja nicht
reicher nur weil man erfolgreichen
Leuten was wegnimmt ja diese Privilegien
kosten die Gesellschaft im Jahr rund 5
Milliarden aber wir hatten auch alle die
gleichen Chancen extrem reich zu werden
man kann sicherlich auch mit eigenem
Einkommen ein beträchtliches Vermögen
aufbauen das gelingt aber nur wenigen
wirklich reiche Personen haben dann doch
das Vermögen meistens von den Eltern
geerbt ja deswegen Augen auf beide
Eltern Wahl
da hatten sie sich ja für so
Mittelschicht Eltern entschieden warum
er welke warum haben sie Geld Allergie
oder was
okay also wir halten fest ihr Haus
wollen sie nicht früher vererben
was ist denn mit der Sendung hier die
ist ja noch gut im Schuss gibt's da
keinen Jungen
talentierten Comedian den sie die
vererben können
fällt mir keine ein till rein das meine
Mutter
hallo Leute Ich bin's der
[Musik]
heute-ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
Scheiß und liegt
[Musik]
dann abonniert jetzt den Kanal
was zur Hölle ist ein Mähne Ersteller